[MUSIC PLAYING]
I felt like I was
just cast yesterday,
and now the show's out.
And we're promoting it, and
I'm here with all my, you know,
people.
And then I haven't
seen them in so long.
Such a huge celebration.
It feels like
a family reunion.
It's like a dream.
I'm, like, still
taking this in.
I feel like if I look around too
much, I'm going to freak out.
I'm really excited for the
world to meet Iman Vellani
and see her performance
as Kamala Khan
because it's absolutely the
heart and centaur of the show.
And I think people
are going to love her.
Iman Vellani, she is
Kamala Khan, you know.
She's the biggest Marvel
fan you can imagine.
It's being myself
on a larger scale.
Like, I get to go to
work and play dress up.
It's literally what I
did when I was a kid.
And, so, yeah, it's quite easy.
I just put a lot of my real
life into Kamala's character
and making her as
authentic as possible.
Are you sure that
you can keep that on?
It's an homage.
- It's a lawsuit.
- Great.
Then I'll meet Captain
Marvel in court.
Won't be the first case
in the American judiciary
to hug it out.
Our cast is-- it's so close.
And we're, like, best friends.
And everything you see on screen
is how it is in real life.
And so just that
relationship and getting
to spend so much time with
these incredible people.
When I have scenes
with Iman and Rish,
we just have so much fun.
I wish I had more
scenes with Saagar.
Every time I'm with him, I just
break, and I start laughing.
It's the camaraderie
of the cast.
I mean, you know, we
all are best friends.
I'm very excited
for people finally--
because we've been working
on this for a very long time,
finally-- get to
me not just Kamala,
but the entire cast, and in
particular, her family, who
from the comics were such
a great ensemble and now
have been brought to
life in an amazing way.
I wanted to layer as much
as I could a strong woman,
matriarch of her household
and is loving and kind,
but can throw down.
This is one family, Pakistani
immigrant family, in America.
We just segue and
assimilate with everybody
else so beautifully.
So you'll see customs.
You'll see religious festivals.
The Khan family is perfect.
They really are.
I want to be adopted by them.
Kamala Khan is a teenage girl.
So she experiences all
of the same boy trauma.
Boys.
Excuse me.
Yeah.
You're kind of on my shirt.
Sorry.
It's high school.
You know, there's
always that drama bit.
You know, Kamran comes in, and,
you know, Bruno sees him and is
like, who is this, you know?
And I don't know.
It'll be cool for
the fans to see.
And I think a lot of
teenagers will relate to it.
It starts out as a
story in Jersey City
and then expands to
the entire globe.
Having a show with this type
of representation in the MCU
is huge and people being
able to turn on Disney Plus
and see somebody that looks
just like them and, you know,
find a different
character that they relate
to because I think we have
such a beautiful diverse group
of personalities.
You're not going to believe
what you're going to see.
Marvel superheroes are bit.
They're brawny.
They're the corporate
giants, et cetera, et cetera.
They're from other worlds.
This is real world.
And real world has heroes.
And you can be a hero too.
Just believe because Marvel
will make you believe.